تعلمت الغوص وانا صغير يمكن ما يقارب وانا
عمري 14 سنه بعدها استمريت في الغوص الحر
ومن خلالها اتجهت الى قوائح تبع تاجر او
تمرنا على القواسه بعد الخيار خيار البحر
فاول كنا نقول في منطقه البريقه بعدين
اتجهنا للبحر الاحمر
[موسيقى]
تعلمت القوس في معهد بادي للغوص وحصلت على
شهاده وترخيص دولي كما اتجهت بعدها القوس
في مناطق اخرى مثل ارتيريا والبحر السعودي
كله بعدها القوس هذا بعد الخيار كان خيار
البحر تبع تاجر وفي اصابتي هذه
ذهبت الى منطقه اسمها عبد الكوري هناك
اتجهنا في القوس بعد الخيار تاجر وكان
الحساب كميه كبيره الحمد لله في خلال
اسبوعين يمكن في حدود اسبوعين هذا صفت
بشلال الرباعي بسبب الطلوع السريع بسبب
نبات كميه الاكسجين على الدبات الغوص
صعود نسميه سعود الطراري من بعد خمسين متر
ما سبب لي اعاقه رباعيه كانت رباعيه
[موسيقى]
البحر قبل ما تعصبت قصيت البيت فتره هي 15
سنه يجي بعضها حصلت دعم من دعمونا بهذا
البوت والقال محرك جزاهم الله خير والحمد
لله استمريت رجعت البحر عدت للبحر والحمد
لله الان ماشي الدنيا دنيا ماشي الحمد لله
البار سبحان الله بفضل الله ثم هذا هو
مصدر رزق
وبنفس الوقت راحه نفسيه عندما تحس بضيق
تجي للبحر
تحسن يعني من فراقك سبحان الله يعني واحد
ما يشتهي همومه يضيق ولا حاجه يقص عند
البحر يفك لك همومك يفك لك كل شيء حتى لو
ما كانت في البيت كان تتمنى اعود البحر بس
جالس مقيد سبحان الله ما بيت حيله بفضل
الله جابوا
هذا وكانت تتمنى سبحان الله جالي قارب وقت
لي محرك بفضل الله ثم بفضل فاعلين الخير
سبحان الله
[موسيقى]
والحمد لله الاعاقه هذه مش مش وقفة للحياه
الاعاقه سبحان الله تستمر تستمر الحياه ما
احد المعاق الذي يجلس يطلب الناس ولا هذا
داخل بيته ما يخرج يعني
لكن الحمد لله الاعاقه هذه زادت على
البحر اذهب الى اماكن بعيده في الاصطياد
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]